and David thanks for that introduction
you know I really mean it
it makes a difference in people's lives
what we're doing or what you all are
supporting and Dina Titus and Steve
Horsford two of the best members of the
Congress that I've ever known for
there you are
and we have the Attorney General here
too
folks of you know Aaron and state and
local tribal leaders are here with the
tribal leaders stand up because I don't
know how many are here
because I would
there you go people good to see you man
by the way
it's Indian nations Indian Nation
I'm here today to talk about initial
affecting every single American
your health care
and I want to first thank the health
care workers in this room you know the
best of times I really mean them
in the best of times you do the Lord's
work but over the last three years
during the pandemic you've literally
risked your lives for the rest of us
health care workers have put their lives
on the line and it matters and it really
really matters and I think imperative
American public beginning to understand
just how consequential you are you're
used to going to the dock where they're
not used to the dock going into a tough
area to take care of them and we lost a
million people and we would have lost a
lot fewer we started earlier not because
of the doc's decisions but because of
other decisions made
oh wow I didn't see you all up there
holy mackerel don't jump
[Laughter]
well all Americans deserve peace of mind
that if illness strikes or they have an
accident occurs in their family they can
get the care they need but they can
afford the care they need
but the truth is too many folks lie in
bed at night staring at the ceiling
wondering what they would do if
something happened if their spouse got a
serious illness or they got very sick
their child got sick and something
happens to them you know I remember we
lived in a I raised in a normal middle
class home back in Delaware a
three-bedroom house with four kids and
and a Grandpop living with us a split
level home and my bedroom was next to my
mom and dad's my me and my three
brothers and we had two sets of bugs and
you could tell when Dad was was rest was
Restless I remember one night true story
one night my dad
I could feel like he was rolling in bed
because the headboard was hit the side
of the the wall and it might and I next
morning asked my I said God's truth
that's my mom I said I was in I think a
junior in high school
so what's the matter with Dad he said he
just we just lost our insurance his
business was no longer going to cover
insurance from employees
it was a consequential decision
it affected my dad and would have
affected if any one of us had gotten
really sick what happens do you have to
sell the house do you have to make some
kind of sacrifice that exceeds what is
actually reasonable
and it's about your dignity
you know do you have enough insurance
can you afford these medical bills can
you get if it gets bad enough do you
have to do something drastic in order to
pay for it
and for seniors on fixed income who
often need expensive medications to stay
healthy the constant question is can
they pay for the medications can they
pay the bills without without giving up
the important elements of their life
because the bottom line is at the end of
the month do you have enough to pay all
that you need and take care of the
exigencies that occur
it was not just the elderly it's almost
every family out there it's not just
your health it's about your dignity it's
about your security
that's why my Administration is focused
intensely
intensely getting more people Affordable
Health Care by long prescription drug
costs and giving families just a little
bit of my dad would say a little bit of
breathing room
we passed the historic laws to get that
done
and now we're moving quickly to
implement those laws so people can feel
the effects of what we did we passed
them last year but it didn't take effect
until January and first thing we did
was to help people who were truly
struggling to gain access to Affordable
Health Care through the Affordable
Health Care Act and that are better
known as Obamacare
I signed a rescue plan that increased
the coverage and lowered prices for
Affordable Health Care saving millions
of people about 800 a year
my new budget
[Applause]
and my new budget for this year makes
that permanent almost one hundred
thousand of add-ins
get their health care through the
Affordable Health Care Act and three
hundred thousand have coverage because
of expanded medicaid under the
Affordable Health Care Act unfortunately
my mag and by the way I mean this
sincerely this is not a broad criticism
of all Republicans this is not your
father's Republican Party
this is a different breed of cat now
that's in charge no but I'm but think
think about it
you know I knew a lot of good
Republicans have represented this state
as senators they were friends we
disagreed but they had they they they
were conservative Republicans
but these Maga Republicans there are
different they're just they're different
they continue to be determined to repeal
the Affordable Care Act
and you know it's hard to believe but
they've already voted to change or get
rid of the Affordable Care Act since it
passed 50 times
5-0 they failed every time
and the one thing I want you to know
about the Affordable Care Act is that
the way for people of pre-existing
conditions to get health care
if you have a pre-existing condition and
you can't afford your health care
private plans
you do not get coverage anywhere
and it's the only outfit if in fact you
do away with affordable care if you have
if you have a pre-existing condition you
don't get coverage otherwise
if migrant Republicans had their way as
many as 100 million people with
pre-existing conditions would lose their
protection that's a fact
and folks look the Affordable Health
Care Act also means by which millions of
hard-working Americans have access to
preventative care like cancer screenings
Mega Republicans put that at risk as
well
and nearly 40 million Americans would be
in danger of losing coverage completely
if they were to succeed
we're making health care more affordable
in other ways as well
last year I proposed a piece of
legislation called the inflation
reduction Act
which I could we've got
[Applause]
we got a lot of things done bipartisanly
this one was there was not any support
on the other team at all
but the result of the law is that
seniors on Medicare
get common vaccines for things like
tetanus whooping cough shingles they get
them for free now
they used to cost them up to 200 per
shot averaged a hundred dollars per shot
the new data released today shows that
if our plan had been in place in 2021
three point three point four million
seniors including 24 000 nevadan seniors
would have saved an average of seventy
dollars
you know America spends more on
prescription drugs than any advanced
Nation on Earth more than any advanced
Nation on Earth
you name the drug you have to take and I
can take you to French and get it to you
a hell of a lot cheaper to Canada
England throughout Europe
it's not fair
but after Decades of trying to take on
big Pharma we finally finally won
now instead of paying whatever the drug
company wants to charge you Medicare
Medicare will be able to negotiate
prices Medicare provides
[Applause]
will drive time from prices because we
give Medicare the power the same power
of the Department of Veterans Affairs
has they can negotiate what they're
going to pay for whatever drugs they're
prescribing to their to the military
well I know many of you are Health Care
Professionals you understand this better
than anybody else for example insulin
was invented a hundred years ago
and the guy who invented decided not to
patent it because he wanted to be
available
it only costs ten dollars a vial to make
ten dollars a vial if you count
everything expanded you can say you get
up to 13 bucks if you talk about
packaging shipping and the rest
and guess what
they're being charged hundreds of
dollars a while
so beginning January 1st to this year we
know we passed the law last year wasn't
until January 1st I kept telling people
it was coming we capped the cost of
insulin at 35 dollars
thirty five dollars for seniors on
Medicare
and folks if it had been in effect in
2020 nearly 11 000 Nevada seniors would
have saved a marriage of 439 dollars on
their insulin
but I've been calling on my colleagues
to cap the cost of for everyone
you know including two hundred thousand
children who have type 1 diabetes who
didn't need insulin every day to stay
alive I was doing a town hall meeting in
Northern Virginia last year and a woman
stood up very sophisticated lady she
said I have two girls
they both have type 1 diabetes and she
said and I can't afford I can't afford
it so we have to do we have to ration
the insulin between them
talk about being deprived of your
dignity man looking at your child
knowing if they don't get the insulin
their life is literally in danger and
you've got to stand there
and not know what to do
folks my budget's going to require it
and guess what the good news is that Eli
Lilly the biggest insulin maker in the
United States of America announced that
they're going to answer my call and
they're going to make the in this
incident available to everyone in
America for 35 dollars
[Applause]
[Music]
yesterday Nova disk another drug maker
announced they're cutting their prices
as well
look folks
another aspect to the inflation
reduction Act is a fancy sound and
phrase but as a drug companies that
raise prices faster than faster than
inflation
have to pay back the difference to
Medicare
so if they're raising the price and
Medicare and and you have the
circumstance where the inflation is up
four percent and they increase it 12
percent or 15 percent they have to pay
the difference to Medicare
yesterday I learned that last quarter
drug companies hiked the prices for 27
drugs that are on the market above the
new limit
now those manufacturers would have to
pay the difference back to Medicare as a
result the Department of Health and
Human Services estimate
this will make co-pays for those drugs
will be as much as 390 dollars cheaper
for seniors
look it's going to change the way drugs
are priced lower the cost for seniors
long term
and is equally consequential to me that
as many of you in this room know
we're capping out a pocket drug expenses
for seniors on Medicare at a maximum of
two thousand dollars a year beginning
next year but but right now
right now we have regardless of how much
they cumulatively are paying for all the
drugs they need
and now it's Captain because I've been
my family is
been deeply involved as a consequence of
cancer and my son died of stage
my son dying
stage three glioblastoma because he's
exposed those burn pits for a year in
Iraq
um and my phone anyway you all how many
here have had you or a family member be
diagnosed with cancer raise your hand
probably is the docs now the most
devastating word they can tell a patient
you got a serious heart disease you may
die that's worrisome more people die of
heart disease than they do from cancer
but cancer
it scares the living hell out of every
single person
well folks you know a lot of those drugs
now that are available that are very
helpful and by the way I I've declared a
war on on cancer we've set up no I
really have
I've gotten five billion dollars for
cancer research through NIH like we did
through the defense department for
special weapon systems the same system
but here's the deal
some people are paying a fact ten
thousand twelve fourteen thousand
dollars a year
for expensive treatments like cancer
drugs it's going to give seniors certain
peace of mind because no matter how much
they pay no matter how much they pay
they're not gonna how much the the bills
are they'll never have to pay more than
two thousand dollars a year for all the
drugs they consume
changes the Peace of Mind people have
and guess what it's going to save
seniors money it's also going to save
the government money
and my Republican friends say what are
you going to cut taxes for the wealthy I
said I got a better way of saving money
not a joke
if in fact you limit the amount of money
that can be charged to reasonable prices
by the drug companies you know how much
you'll save this year
160 billion dollars
160 billion dollars why
because it's a 160 billion dollars less
they have to pay out to provide the
drugs for the seniors
so it's not only the right thing to do
it is a conservative thing to do in
terms of cutting the federal budget
but here's the deal
as I've said this is not your father's
Republican party the mega Republican
Congress don't think any of this is a
good idea they think big farmers should
be able to make the exorbitant profits
at the expense of the American people
they've been making
and I want to repeal they want to repeal
the inflation reduction act rollback
savings for seniors add to the deficit
another 1.6 billion and continue to line
the pockets of big Pharma look I'm a
capitalist I want if you go out and make
a lot of money go make the money just
pay your fair share
just just your fair share
oh for real
I have no problem with company making
reasonable profits but my Lord not on
the backs of working families and
seniors and this is really what gets
downwards about fairness fairness and
decency and providing people some
dignity last week I released my budget
I met by the way
and I apologize to the Presidents here
they're tired of hearing me say this I
met with the new Speaker of the House
he said he is threatening that we're
going to let the federal debt not get
paid and put us in turmoil we've never
done that in American history and the
debt is accumulation of debt over 200
years that's the debt we're talking
about and uh and and I want to lay I
said look I'll lay out clearly what we
support I'll lay out my budget on March
the 9th you lay out your budget and
we'll negotiate
will negotiate well you know my dad used
to have an expression for real he said
Joey when someone said I tell you what I
value he'd say don't tell me what you
value show me your budget I'll tell you
what you value show me your budget
oh really think about it
my budget takes steps to lift the burden
on seniors and hardworking Americans so
at the end of the month after busting
their necks and their whole lives they
have a little bit left over
that's what used to be at our kitchen
table at the end of the month is there
anything left you bear your painting do
you have a little bit of room
and again it's about fairness it's about
your dignity
I value everyone having a decent shot
my Republican colleagues now in the
House of Representatives I think it's
fair to say not every one of them most
of them are now at a point they have a
very different value set
we're strengthening Medicare and Social
Security instead of threatening to
eliminate them
and the Maggie Republicans are in
congresswoman are threatening to do you
know when I did I don't know if they saw
the State of the Union
but it was kind of a fascinating thing
no no I didn't say for that reason
[Applause]
I I was a Senator a long time I'm used
to dealing with and speaking to the
Congress and the Senate
and so I'm comfortable when I'm doing
them while I'm standing up there before
all the members of the House in the
Senate and I talked about I read the
programs which some of the leaders have
put forward to in fact cut Social
Security and cut Medicare
and the gentle lady as they say from
Georgia in the mountains of Georgia
stood up and yelled liar liar and then
that generated last time somebody did
that by the way they got censored but no
I'm not joking but here's what happened
then another half a dozen you know liar
a liar we're not going to do that I said
oh
if you remember I said oh you're not
going to cut Social Security Medicare
and they said we're not going against
the whole group because I said everybody
who's not going to cut Social Security
Medicare stand up they stood up and
hollered
well they're all on film
I hope it's true
I Hope they've gotten there
but I'll believe it when I see it look
you paid for Social Security from the
time you got your first check when
you're 16 years old working as a
lifeguard or something okay
and I'm determined to protect them both
there's ways to protect them without
cutting them
look let me close with this
you know let's finish the job
let's protect the lower prescription
drug cost for everyone let's expand
health care for more people to get care
let's keep building the economy from the
middle out and the bottom up
not from the top down and by the way
when that happens when the middle does
well and the bottom Rises the wealthy
still do very very well
and no one I commit to you and I
committed this when I got elected when I
was running no one making less than four
hundred thousand dollars will see a
penny in federal taxes raised as long as
I'm president United States of America
but look
but again
it's about just just paying a fair share
when I got elected there were I think it
was six don't hold me to the exact
number 690 billionaires in America
there's now a thousand note the average
federal tax they pay is
t-h-r-e-e percent
three
they pay a lower tax rate
than the custodians in this building
they play a lower tax rate than any of
you but basically
and so it's just not fair I I think you
should be able to be a billionaire if
you can earn it
but just pay your fair share just pay
something
by the way you know everybody said well
how was I able to have these new
programs
and still cut the deficit 1.7 trillion
dollars the last two years
well it was pretty pretty
straightforward
there were 550 companies of the Fortune
500 that made 40 billion dollars it
didn't pay us penny in tax zero nothing
in taxes
so I said the outrageous
we got votes for it I said they ought to
pay a minimum of 15 percent
15 that's less than y'all pay
guess what
allowed me to cut the deficit
so folks this is about just basic
fairness and decency another radical
about what I'm proposing
and if you look at the polling data it's
overwhelmingly popular what we proposed
matter of fact held a lot more popular
than I am
but I'm serious so I this is no time to
turn around
look
what the American people understandably
a lot of people have lost faith in
government
for a lot of reasons
and here's the deal
we promised these things and they
haven't seen it
I don't know whether you've been
surprised but the number of people
who've come up to me after January 1st
cup you cut my insulin cost thirty five
dollars like I didn't believe government
would really do it
but there's a lot more coming
a lot more common
and again let me end by thanking the
medical people that are here and the
students it really matters
it really really really matters
and all you have to do like many people
in this audience have been a consumer
significant consumer of Health Care
son spent 18 months knowing he was dying
in the hospital
the Dachshund nurses just change it
changed it they they made it
took care of them
my wife and daughter kilma on a trucking
accident
my two boys were expected not to live
you guys saved them
and you saved their sanity as well
so I think that you know we vastly
underestimate you underestimate a
psychological impact you have on people
not just the medical impact yeah
so I'm here to say thank you thank you
thank you
folks
let's remember
[Music]
we forget we are the United States of
America and there's nothing nothing
beyond our capacity if we work together
so let's work together God bless you all
and may God protect our troops
[Applause]